what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
big happy new year to everybody i hope
everybody had a good time last night
hope everybody was safe and i hope
everybody is ready for an awesome year
filled with marvel content of course
spider-man no way home is still in
theaters right now let me know how many
times you've seen it already in the
comments down below unfortunately i got
really sick as most of you know and i've
only seen it four times so far but let
me know how many times you've seen it
and this video is to talk about the
future of marvel studios and what we can
expect in 2022.
let's start off this new year by getting
excited about what's to come this year
and the future years down the road in
the mcu some people are saying that
spider-man no way home was the biggest
that marvel studios can go however i
disagree it is my favorite mcu movie so
far but there is a lot coming so let's
talk about those projects and why we
should be super excited for all of them
and in 2022 if you want to stay up to
date on all things relating to the mcu
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos and we are
still going to be giving away a lot of
really cool items so stay tuned for
these awesome giveaways coming up now
right off the bat i gotta say that i'm
actually more excited for this year than
i was last year yes spiderman no way
home had so much hype to it and we did
get movies like shang qi but overall i
think this year is going to be much
better starting with and we're going to
start with the movies not shows doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness now
if you've seen the trailer you are
probably really excited about this and
you know why i and a lot of fans are
really excited about this it looks
absolutely insane but the biggest part
about this movie is that anything is
possible and here are just some rumors
of what could happen in the film one the
x-men could show up there are rumors
that professor x will be in the film and
two he's going to be a part of the
illuminati the illuminati is a team of
basically all of the leaders of the
different superhero groups in the mcu
and marvel comics in the comics it
consists of professor xavier
representing the x-men mr fantastic
representing the fantastic four doctor
strange of course black bolt of the
inhumans namor the submariner and iron
man representing the avengers now rumors
that the illuminati are going to be in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness are going pretty strong right
now so we could be looking at different
variants of iron man perhaps we'll see
tom cruise's iron man we could see
another captain america namor the
submariner is going to be in black
panther wakanda forever so maybe he gets
introduced in multiverse of madness and
who knows we could see a fantastic four
this could be the old fantastic four
from the fox universe since it's the
multiverse but a new fantastic four
movie is coming within the next few
years so perhaps we get a little bit of
a tease here literally anything is
possible in this movie anybody could be
introduced deadpool could be in this
movie cosmic entities like galactus
could be introduced in this movie it's
going to be absolutely insane and it
looks like we're also going to be
getting strange supreme not to mention
the scarlet witch is probably going to
turn out to be kind of evil in this film
so strange mordo america chavez wong and
a lot of other people might actually
have to fight her there's even a rumor
that she fights professor x and kills
him so if even part of these rumors are
true this movie is going to be
absolutely insane and one of the best
marvel movies of all time and that is
only the start of 2022 for marvel then
we have thor love and thunder now
everything that has been said about this
movie so far from the cast from the
director from the actors everybody they
have all said that this movie goes above
and beyond thor ragnarok and they say
that this movie is crazy we know that
the guardians of the galaxy are going to
be in this movie at least for a part of
it christian bale a phenomenal actor the
batman in the mcu is going to be playing
the bad guy gore the god butcher and of
course rumors that beta ray bill might
show up everyone saying that this movie
is going to be better than thor ragnarok
which is in my top 5 favorite mcu movies
of all time and if this is going to be
better then i'm definitely here for this
and not to mention chris hemsworth looks
to be in the greatest shape of his life
for this movie and that's saying
something because chris hemsworth is
freaking jacked all the time and then
not to mention we have a new thor jane
foster is going to be wielding mjolnir
and she's going to be a female version
of thor they're also going to explore
the comics where she gets cancer which
is going to be probably really really
emotional so it's not just going to be a
ton of action and a ton of comedy but
it's going to be a pretty serious movie
as well but i'm really excited that
they're bringing her back and of course
to end the year we are going to get
black panther 2 wakanda forever now this
is a little bit of a bittersweet movie
obviously since chadwick boseman is no
longer with us and marvel studios made
it very clear that they're not recasting
t'challa however rumors still fly that
there will be a new black panther
perhaps by the end of this movie or down
the road but we'll have to wait and see
on that however the biggest rumor right
now is that t'challa and nakia had a son
this would obviously be an off-screen
thing that nobody saw but could come to
light in black panther ii and eventually
if this does happen that son could go on
to take on the black panther mantle and
become the king of wakanda regardless it
does look like we will be seeing a new
black panther in some way shape or form
maybe not a true black panther but maybe
somebody who has taken a heart-shaped
herb and perhaps the most exciting part
of black panther ii is that they are
introducing neymar the submariner and
atlantis and namor is technically a
mutant so depending on what route marvel
studios goes with namor they could be
introducing mutants to the mcu in black
panther wakanda forever and i'm sure
that's enough to get anybody excited for
black panther 2. and those are our
movies right now and if you ask me
that's a pretty good lineup for movies
in 2022 for marvel studios and we won't
dive too far into 2023 but we have the
marvel slash captain marvel 2 ant-man
and the wasp quantomania which is going
to introduce kang the conqueror and
modoc and then of course to top it all
off we're going to have the guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. and that only takes us
till may of 2023 so there could be
another movie after that that hasn't
been announced yet and those are the
movies for 2022 but let's talk about the
shows for 2022 because we have a lot of
really cool ones starting with we
believe moon night it's interesting
because we don't have any official dates
for any of these upcoming disney plush
shows in 2022 but we believe moon night
is going to be the next disney plush
show moon knight is going to be played
by oscar isaac he's going to play mark
spector who is an ex-marine turned
mercenary who has dissociative identity
disorder so we'll see him take on
multiple different identities throughout
the series and to top it all off he's
been chosen by the egyptian moon god
konchu to become the moon's knight and
we've recently found out that this show
is actually going to be rather dark and
kind of violent which not to sound you
know completely messed up here it
actually makes me kind of excited for
this i should say more excited because
i'm already really really excited for
this this is probably my most
anticipated disney plus show of 2022.
i'm super excited for it but we do have
other awesome shows coming as well like
she-hulk there's a lot to she-hulk to be
excited for one of course is a new hulk
jennifer walters played by tatiana
menslee is a lawyer who specializes in
superhuman oriented legal cases so
through this show and through her cases
we might actually get introduced to a
lot of new superheroes here because
that's what she deals with not to
mention mark ruffalo is returning as the
hulk and he is no longer professor hulk
when we saw him in the post-credits
scene for shangqi and the legend of the
ten rings spoiler warning he was no
longer professor hulk he was just a
human he was bruce banner so somehow
he's found a way to turn it on and off
again he can be bruce or the hulk but
he's no longer both so that story alone
is enough to get excited about and of
course the big rumor that matt murdock
will be in the show and not just for
like a little cameo but will be a
consistent part of this show which of
course makes sense because he's also a
lawyer and he's also daredevil and i
know everybody is really excited to see
charlie cox return as daredevil and then
we have secret invasion which is going
to be bringing back samuel l jackson as
nick fury and the scroll talos played by
ben mendelsohn now this show has the
potential ability to simply melt our
minds as some heroes that we know and
love could be revealed to have been
scroll the entire time so if there's any
show out there that we're about to get
that could offer us some very very big
surprises it's this show so i'm really
excited for it and then the show that i
know a lot of people are really really
wanting to see and anticipating miss
marvel before she joins captain marvel
in the marvels in 2023 of course she has
her own show where she'll be introduced
she's an inhuman in the comics so there
is a chance that miss marvel could
introduce the inhumans to the mcu but
even if they don't go that route we are
still getting kamala khan in the mcu and
rumor has it they've kind of altered her
powers a little bit making them work in
a slightly different way so i'm excited
to see how they do that and to top it
all off something that i know a lot of
people are excited for the guardians of
the galaxy holiday special now we can
assume this will be in december since
it's a holiday special and i know some
people have kind of batted their eyes at
this stating that it's just going to be
playful and funny and cheerful which i'm
sure it is going to be but james gunn
has actually mentioned that you kind of
are going to have to watch this to
understand guardians of the galaxy vol
3. so yes it's going to be fun it's
going to be funny and cheerful but it's
also going to be important and tell us a
little bit about what's happened lately
with the guardians of the galaxy and
that's what's coming from marvel studios
in 2022 a lot to look forward to but let
me know what you're most excited to see
in the comments down below for me it's
gotta be doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness moon knight and
thor love and thunder but hey let me
know what you think down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu videos and news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof